my parents always wanted me to be a
doctor but a doctor that studies how
vultures eat dead things is probably not
the type of doctor my parents had in
mind
I study Bulger scavenging behavior and
how vultures affect crime scenes I'm
here to talk to you about how we take
vultures for granted in forensic science
before we do that I want to tell you a
story so we're gonna take a trip Oh
1,000 of us it's May 2014 and we're
standing in a park in Nashville
Tennessee because we've been at a horse
race as we wait for the Porta Potty we
see two ladies and their Sunday best
heels pearls and lovely floppy derby
hats at any moment we expect them to
start talking about their grandma's
slide China but they don't instead we
hear them say oh look something must be
dead we look up and to the left and see
vultures circling round and round it
occurred to me at this very moment that
if these ladies at the Derby are aware
of vultures connection to death then why
aren't we talking more about these birds
at crime scenes people know that
vultures are connected to death but they
don't really understand how for example
here's an email I received from a
detective in Louisiana Lauren there's
been a kidnapping
what buzzards or vultures do we have in
Louisiana before we address the
kidnapping I'll first address this
Buzzard vulture question I get all the
time buzzards don't live in the United
States they are hawks that live in
Europe the big black birds you see
circling in the sky within the u.s. are
vultures the two types of vultures that
live in Louisiana or the turkey vulture
and black vulture to fully understand
the role of vultures and forensic
science I'll walk you through this
forensic case from the email
certain things become apparent we can
assume the detective thinks the
individual is dead and he wants to use
the birds to try to find the body like
the ladies in Nashville
the detective thinks that vultures
circling in the sky will lead him to the
body it's not that simple I don't know
if you've ever seen a vulture up close
or spent much time with them but they're
huge huge six-foot wingspan vultures
circle in the air because they are too
big to flap their wings and fly so they
soar they soar in thermals which are
vortexes or little tornadoes caused by
pressure differences in the air the
forms are out the day as the Sun heats
up the ground therefore when you see a
circling vulture the bird is usually
traveling from point A to B rather than
circling above something dead actually
if you want to use a vulture to try to
find a body look for a vulture in a tree
or on a fence post vultures are too big
and slow to hunt so they have to
scavenge in fact vultures are the only
animals in the world that depend upon
death is a food source the turkey
vultures that you see here is super cool
because it's one of the few bird species
that can actually smell it hones in on
the deceased by sensing a chemical
that's coming off the body during decay
the evolutionary role of the vulture is
to rid the earth of harmful toxins
produced following death once death has
been detected the turkey vulture lands
and quickly scavenges vultures usually
remove the eyes first then tear the skin
start pulling the tissues and leave you
with a skeleton therefore the importance
of ulcers is not in the air but on the
ground
vulture scavenging is somewhat gruesome
if you're ever on a bad first date just
reference this talk and I don't think
you'll have to worry about your
potential suitor giving you another call
although gruesome vultures are key
forensic players and here's why
vultures will consume a dead human just
like they will consume roadkill but you
don't ever hear about that and it's
because vultures are so good at what
they do
if voltar's depend on death for survival
and if they scavenge humans then how can
vultures be absent from forensic
textbooks and training manuals the
answer the tradition has been for
researchers to exclude animal scavengers
from decomposition studies by placing a
cage over the decaying subject matter
why because researchers were afraid an
animal would run away with their subject
matter and they wouldn't have any data
to report consequently excluding animals
results in a lengthy skeletonization
process and this information is
currently what detectives use during
investigations a lot of times at a crime
scene if people see a skeletonized body
they think wow this has been here for a
really long time
undiscovered oh no no no no no vultures
accelerate decay and the skeletonized
body could have been there for as little
as five days if scavenged by vultures
the failure to account for vulture
scavenging can result in forensic
scientists inaccurately estimating how
long someone has been dead and then
searching through the wrong
missing-persons files therefore the goal
is to get forensic scientists to focus
on vulture evidence and to get law
enforcement to consider vulture
scavenging and a possible recent death
when skeletal remains are found let's
get back to the importance of the
kidnapping case I responded to the
detectives and told them that vultures
like areas with water they like areas
with white-tailed deer they typically
arrive within the first five days
falling death they're going to leave an
intact spinal column and feathers
the detectives write back and say we
found the body buried in a shallow grave
we also found the feathers you mentioned
but there appeared to be a problem
because the feathers were located 40
yards from where the body was found the
feathers
next to a bloody pinecone vultures
aren't attracted to blood and they
typically don't wonder they might wonder
forty feet but they're not gonna wander
forty yards that would be a waste of
energy for a bird that doesn't know when
it will get its next meal so my first
job here was to determine if vultures
were at the scene indeed the feather by
the pine cone was consistent with the
turkey vulture so why in the world would
a vulture wonder forty yards one of the
reasons I love vultures is because they
tend to operate in a manner that can be
explained by biology and physics
I started mentally going through the
numerous baiting experiments I had
conducted at a body farm in Texas a body
farm is a place we can donate your body
to science I also went through my
experiences with trapping and GPS
tagging vultures and then the year-long
process of monitoring vultures via
remote GPS technology next I brought up
my field notes and had an aha moment I
knew of two things that would lure
vulture 40 yards from a body guts and
brain matter I presented this
information to the detectives and
learned that they suspected the victim
had been incapacitated by blunt-force
trauma to the head the blow to the head
was thought to have occurred in the area
where the pine cone was found and then
the victim was drugged
40 yards and buried in a shallow grave
this suggested that brain matter was the
litter for the vulture and illustrates
how studying vulture behavior can help
piece together some of the evidence the
detectives also sent me this photo the
victims arm is sticking up out of the
grave as a forensic scientist you have
to think about the whole picture the
feather by the pine cone indicated the
vultures were at the scene this crime
scene photo also depicts characteristic
vulture scavenging behavior we zoom in
we see a white down feather which is
characteristic of the turkey vulture
also note that this skin has a cut like
tear near the wrist the turkey vulture
smells the decay
lands it can get through the pine
needles pull out the hand it's going to
tear the skin with its beak and then
start pulling the soft tissues away from
the bone just tear and pull tear and
pull tear and pull this photo
illustrates the scavenging efficiency of
vultures this is important because it
helps support the timeline the
detectives are putting together for the
murder there's not a whole lot of
evidence you're not likely going to see
the vultures at the crime scene instead
vultures just leave these very subtle
clues rather than looking for the
vulture look for the feathers and
pristine bones vultures are important
because they are so good and fast at
what they do
they're like tornadoes if you blink
you'll miss them I provided my opinion
about the vulture evidence to the
detective and he presented the vulture
evidence in court
the kidnapping case was a death penalty
case and the defendant was found guilty
this case illustrates how studying
vulture behavior helps innovate forensic
science someone who has been murdered
deserves the most thorough investigation
possible when we include vultures in
forensic studies we paint a more
thorough picture of what happened when
it happened and who it happened to so
the next time you are at a crime scene
with a dead body
looked at the ground to find the clues
vultures have left and if anyone ever
brings the vultures on a date you'll
know they're a keeper thank you
[Applause]
[Music]